approximate french I feel like
a giraffe with vertigo brief
woman had required my neighborhood
give reason to catastrophism person
in the guerrillas not only the negative that
do we have a girl this is the
geography are at this price the doubt is
in the rap ok where is what some
want to lock the floor
where some journalists from where
some politicians want to impose a
terrorism a phone well they
will always find people in front of them
who are there who will contradict me their
promotion of loyalty cards for
the crematoriums to be offered from
anger tenfold my strength that we
fermions Bertin I will take classes
solfège street solferino 4au
binational is to be citizen grosso
modo even when growing up small
bikes do not become big bikes
he made the colonial cut in this
story nobody would have petals
you will do me memoria do we know that maps
but the whine of victims is not
for me clippings
Indicators badly are a few small
ads should so a newspaper juni
rolling mill he put to flap the zinc the
debate on secularism is for me very
revealing a certain desire to
force to be forced people to what they
be in a single vision of this
what is the secularity of what is France
I am in this process with a
other star states with the culture the
other soldiers that I use is the
buttock of culture facing the culture of
strength and to dogs what he thinks
street lights it takes laws for them
meaning
take their mouse are advertising
for its garbage the selective sorting of
waste it starts in France to me
blame because I'm not allowed
to me to have a charlie spirit to have
the spirit free cats do not know him
I do not get me spada satirical
to be irreverent to be
blasphemous
you make food before singing
jacques the media maes not a place
of my flesh body c4n it's crazy this
what is said about the tasks at marek
all the tears of Africa are not doing
more if what I'm fighting against
everyday party is the fear yours
but this moment that I will develop in
November was saying to blunt or do not
switchgrass
it invited people and gatherings
it wanted to remind us that the Muslim
could be part of a process of
building a national park with
all citizens be told in
passing I will become maybe
consultant at culturesfrance
it's the strength of culture facing the
culture of strength